opening catchphrase I'm Greg Alva and
I'm John so we watched the movie a few
days ago and with e3 going on we didn't
have time to review it get our minds
focused on it and not as many people
will watch our reviews as our reactions
but we're gonna talk about it anyway
Incredibles 2 people the par family is
back Brad Bird writing and directing
this film this movie is something that I
was highly anticipating Incredibles 1 is
arguably my favorite Pixar movie
actually I gotta tell you right off the
bat you can click off the review right
now forget watch time on YouTube it is
one of just the best sequels I've ever
seen and if you want to talk about the
category of what a sequel is this is one
of the best sequels I've ever seen I
might have enjoyed this a little more
than the first one cuz the first one is
a movie that I've seen a couple times I
really appreciate and for some reason I
had don't carry that like intense love
is something at the top of my Pixar list
but at the same time I have mad respect
for that movie coming out of that this
one really dazzled me and I think in
fact it made me kind of appreciate the
first one that much more so this is a
slam dunk
oh I get us out of the way right now the
big question with any sequel when people
ask is like which one did you prefer I
don't think it's necessary to try to do
that for this specific one I think
there's such good companion pieces you
watch part one you're gonna want to
watch part two and it's just as
satisfying as the first one
then it feeds right into part two yeah
picks up wherever the last one left off
literally there are elements of the
first one that I really do prefer when I
was thinking about it I was thinking was
thinking about us thinking of myself the
thoughts of a coma the thinking the
elements that I preferred in the first
one only work because of the fact that
it is a first one and that it is an
introduction this is a continuation and
it does explore different elements I
don't know how other people are phrasing
and I haven't heard any other reviews
yet but I think the first one is more of
like a commentary on superhero films and
I think this one is just a really good
superhero film serves to still
deconstruct certain LM sure sure sure I
don't think there would be an
Incredibles movie that doesn't kind of
respond to the current state of
superheroes
little bit it's an advocate for
superheroes we've got two plots going on
the action driven plot deals with
Elastigirl there's these characters
brother and sister Evelyn and Winston
Dever
played by Catherine Keener and Bob
Odenkirk who you kids might know from
better call Saul all those kids love
that Breaking Bad spinoff there are
these billionaires who basically want to
help superheroes become legit they're
lobbying for the legality of superheroes
once more to do that they want
Elastigirl to basically go out there and
be their poster girl for this whole
superhero movement the other storyline
is because the lots of girls do in that
mr. incredible has to take the backseat
and be the stay-at-home dad and take
care of the kids and going back and
forth between these two stories of the
last circle storyline I thought was
great what's cool about this one is the
first one was mr. incredible story and
this one is really elastic girl's
journey this is her like crazy action
adventure and there are some brilliant
action moments with her it sees some of
it in the trailer with this motorcycle
sequences chase moment watching Brad
Birds direction on this reminded me is
so much why I love the action scenes of
the first one is he really does think
about okay this is an animated movie
what can we pull off here that would old
man work an animated film and he does
that just with the chase sequence I was
mesmerised there have been people
complaining about that part of the
storyline saying like ah the tram ISM is
destroying this movie but really it
makes a lot of sense why you focus on
the last two go for the action portions
yeah they even go so far as to say of
all the superheroes we've got right now
you're kind of the one who causes the
least amount of damage yeah you know
there's the least amount of argument
against you and so they pull her into
this and the movie never gets overly
preachy with that stuff like it barely
even stops to give you a direct message
about it it's really about it yeah yeah
it's just Elastigirl kickin and doing
her thing you know kicking buns mm-hmm
and doing her thing
kids kids stay off that better console
and then with Bob storyline he's taking
care of the kids a big part of that is
he's discovering that Jack Jack has some
and they tease it at the end of the
first one has some superpowers don't
want to give anything away here easily
easily Jack's
is the scene-stealer of this movie
jack-jack is so much fun biggest laughs
biggest collapse throughout this entire
film and the most memorable sequences
when I think of Incredibles 2 I think of
Jack Jack's moment specifically I really
don't want to go away it was just such a
nice surprise and I think a big part of
why Bob storyline works so well here is
because it not only amplifies the
emotional human side of Bob it amplifies
the emotional human side of the kid
violet is a character who I kind of
don't really care for in the first one
and this movie really cared a lot about
her yes but more than just she gets some
cooler scenes she gets some more like
teenager stuff to do yeah and the
bonding relationship between - and mr.
incredible is another big part of this
movie - having to do his homework and
contend to dad having to teach - having
to relearn math yeah like that get good
at being an actual dad and the pro help
violet out with her love life and what I
found fascinating about this movie was I
thought this stuff with mr. incredible
being a stay-at-home dad might be the
dull part of the movie or the not as
interesting part in some ways I
preferred that more yeah because I hate
women and female propaganda is just the
stupidest thing ever a man taking care
of his family in an effortless kind of
way this movie reverses the roles in a
way that never feels cloying or preachy
or anything like that it's so much fun
watching mr. incredible learn how to do
dad stuff yeah and be one step ahead of
- is lessons and managing Jack Jack and
all the way you get like the action
superhero stuff primarily from
Elastigirl storyline but then you get
like the heart and the emotions from the
mr. incredible storyline and his
storyline it has some of the biggest
laughs in it I would say this movie is
funnier than the first one well III
would say there are moments in the first
one that can only be captured within a
part one of a franchise like this the
family uniting and getting the chills
from that and getting kind of teary-eyed
from how like awesome that is you're not
gonna get that in this movie because
we've already got that all taken care of
I would still say this one is a lot more
energy
fake and funnier than the first one oh
yeah and it's perfectly updated too now
it's got all the proper sensibilities
without feeling like it's lost its soul
or anything like that and the animation
is improved as well but it they don't
like go too far to improve who are you
like what the hell is this notice there
are so many finer textures and things
definitely move a bit more fluidly like
it's beautiful but it's still that same
Incredibles design yeah I would say that
violet and Elastigirl get a shine more
in this movie I think the only missing
ingredient here but they supplement it
with something the only missing
ingredient here would be - having that
moment in the movie that's just so cool
because in the first Incredibles that's
one of my favorite moments when -
discovers you can run on water and then
in this movie he doesn't really get that
super cool moment like you get some -
stuff yeah he gets a lot of punchlines
he's funny there's no like action moment
that really stands out for him however
you know what a great yeah yeah and
that's what I would also say about mr.
incredible and Elastigirl Elastigirl
gets a shine more in the action parts
then mr. incredible does but you get a
whole new layer - mr. incredible that
was super rewarding the only thing I
think I could have used a little bit
more of Lucius was frozen really just
him being Lucius like there's some cool
action with you get more frozen with
less Lucius yeah exactly and I do always
love like especially I think back to the
first one like the buddy dynamic between
him and Bob and the PA is a lot of fun
so I did kind of missed that but still I
mean Sam Jackson's a lot of fun in this
role still and there's a couple of new
characters in here there's one new
character with superpowers that I don't
recall seeing in the trailers but Sophia
Bush plays a character named void she
gets an action sequence that is one of
the highlight action moments of the
movie as well that was another moment or
like that's Brad Bird right there yeah
I've seen this power before in other
movies but this is how you do it here in
an animated movie yeah the villain that
sees in this movie - screen slaver an
interesting villain I mean it's not like
the majority the focus goes on the
villain in this movie that's the other
thing - I would probably say about the
first Incredibles I preferred is that is
the villain of the first Incredibles
this room going to spoiler territory if
I had to reveal why I just found there
is a more surprise and a personal twist
behind the first Incredibles as opposed
to what they do with screen slaver here
but there
so some cool elements a touch on that
you think this movie's gonna make some
commentary on it doesn't really go all
out with this commentary there but it's
not about that you don't want to give it
away you know people might be able to
predict twists and whatever from just
watching this movie but it's not even
about the twist you know it's not about
any of those things so even if it's
predictable it's not about that yeah
kind of meet you halfway on that one the
first movie definitely has a more
rewarding more personal villain although
I will say I thought the screen slaver
was surprisingly intense and kind of
scary to behold and some of my favorite
sequences in the movie involve the
screen slavery yeah I do I think it's a
strong villain there's no doubt about
that I'm glad you said that because I
don't want them to miss communicating
that I don't like the screen slaver and
I do think that that is a distinctive
villain especially moving on to a part -
it doesn't need to be the same I was
kind of thinking is this really gonna
get really dark minute there oh my gosh
this is gonna go down that path I think
the common thing that people will say
with the sequels that have this much
anticipation this much high because
stuff like it doesn't feel as fresh I
wouldn't even use that word as I still
think it feels fresh it's like it didn't
feel like it was weird to watch a movie
that hasn't had a sequel and like over a
decade and then to not feel like time
has passed at the same time like yes I
think it's a perfect companion piece to
part one I think their elements and part
one that I prefer but there's definitely
elements here that I also prefer it's
funnier it's more energetic I would say
there they're equal I know some people
for the first time but for the second I
would say they're both equal hey man
this is definitely a Toy Story 2 not a
cars to first it was pretty equivalent
to odd how dare you besmirched the good
name of cars 3 being marginally ok or
than carsten Incredibles 2 gets whatever
high rating that other critics give
movies I give it a hundred Stockman's
hundred and fifty thousand Ellis's I
give it a million subscriptions to the
Tyrone Magnus channel I am late to the
party
it's reaction TV well guys why don't you
comment below and tell us if you
upset that we did not say that this is
the best Fantastic Four movie ever made
reason why we did it it's not a
Fantastic Four movie none all right you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click the notification about the
subscribe buttons do not work these days
you can check us out on patreon we got
full a TV show reactions weekly Q&A it's
music video coverage would love to have
you become a patronage act